Leandro is an amazing guy
in a slum in Rio,
and he created a recycling project in the slum.
At the end of last year, December 16,
he received an eviction order
by the Rio de Janeiro state government
giving him two weeks to leave the space
that he had been using for two years.
The plan was to hand it over to a developer,
who planned to turn it into a construction site.
Leandro started a campaign using one of our tools,
the Pressure Cooker,
the same one that Bia and Jovita used,
and the state government changed their minds
before Christmas Eve.
These stories make me happy,
but not just because they have happy endings.
They make me happy because they are
happy beginnings.
The teacher and parent community at Bia's school
is looking for other ways they could improve
that space even further.
Leandro has ambitious plans
to take his model to other low-income communities in Rio,
and Jovita is volunteering at the police unit
that she helped created.
Bia, Jovita and Leandro
are living examples of something
that citizens and city governments around the world
need to know:
We are ready.
As citizens, we are ready
to decide on our common destinies,
because we know that the way we distribute power
says a lot about how we actually value everyone,
and because we know
that enabling and participating in local politics
is a sign that we truly care
about our relations to one another,
and we are ready to do this
in cities around the world right now.
With the Our Cities network,
the Meu Rio team
hopes to share what we have learned
with other people who want to create
similar initiatives in their own cities.
We have already started doing it in São Paulo
with incredible results,
and want to take it to cities around the world
through a network of citizen-centric,
citizen-led organizations
that can inspire us,
challenge us, and remind us to demand
real participation in our city lives.
It is up to us
to decide whether we want schools
or parking lots,
community-driven recycling projects
or construction sites,
loneliness or solidarity, cars or buses,
and it is our responsibility to do that now,
for ourselves, for our families,
for the people who make our lives worth living,
and for the incredible creativity,
beauty, and wonder that make our cities,
in spite of all of their problems,
the greatest invention of our time.
Obrigado. Thank you.
(Applause)